Пил, дим, село і техно.
А я сам складу найгарнішу купу з усіх, от побачите.  От приходьте через хвилин 30, тут буде найкраще.
Це рейв-толока, яка щовихідних приваблює десятки людей.
Тут атмосфера якраз та, що треба.
Тут дуже класне ком'юніті…
У цьому році я з'їздив уперше на пасхальну толоку, і з того часу скасував усі плани на вихідні, щоб їздити сюди.
Валерій - учитель математики. Це вже його сьома толока.
В якийсь момент через роботу знайомитись з новими людьми стало важкувато.
Коли ти знайомишся з людьми під час ланцюжка цегли,
під час спільної роботи, у вас якась спільна справа, то комунікація набагато легша,
і тому нових знайомих знайти набагато легше.
Це село Ягідне на Чернігівщині.
Торік воно пережило окупацію і постраждало від бойових дій.
Завдання для толокерів на сьогодні - розібрати завали зруйнованого спортзалу.
Формуємо ланцюжки!
Ті, хто до цього стояли в ланцюжках, просимо переходити на збирання цегли і оббивку.
На жаль, спортивний зал не підлягає відновленню.
Його збиралися бульдозером взагалі знести й вивезти усе на смітник, всі матеріали.
Ми зрозуміли, що там є багато цеглин, здали ці цеглини на експертизу і виявили,
що ці цеглини можна перевикористовувати на будівництві надалі.
Молодь добровільно платить невеликий внесок,
аби приїхати сюди й попрацювати під музику.
Для багатьох - це відпочинок, який можна собі дозволити під час війни.
Я з Запоріжжя. У мене дуже багато друзів з Херсона.
Це був дуже важкий тиждень. І я дуже радію, що зараз в мене є нагода
хоча б трошки відволіктися від усіх цих новин і всього того, що дуже відчувається.
У мене брат на фронті, у мене багато друзів,
знайомих на фронті, відповідно, це… великий стрес.
Учасників привозять автобусами з Києва, годують.
Хоча це здебільшого типова міська молодь, тут почуваються, як вдома.
Ну, я сам із Чернігова, Чернігівська область така рідна.
І робиш щось корисне, я думаю, це в першу чергу мотивує.
Один раз, коли ми приїжджали, я не пам'ятаю, яке це було село, чи Буди, чи Слобода,
то нас місцеві зустрічали зі сльозами, нас обнімали,
це ми - один народ, одна родина, одна сім'я, і потрібно допомагати.
Толоки на Чернігівщині почалися майже одразу після деокупації.
За цей час місцеві вже звикли - сільські рейви нікого не дивують.
Коли ми вперше приїхали, казали: Боже, хто вони понаїхали, якісь зеки,
вони всі в наколках, в якихось незрозумілих зачісках, незрозумілих нарядах.
А потім десь толок п'ять, і нам вже:
ой, діти приїхали, давайте вас нагодуємо, давайте вареники, давайте ще щось.
Дітки молодці. Молоді, як мурашечки, я теж чоловіку кажу.
Скільки вже нас кидали, дивіться. Молодці!
Ягідне - це те саме село, де росіяни майже місяць тримали в шкільному підвалі 370 місцевих жителів.
Дванадцятеро з них загинули.
Пані Тамара разом зі своїм песиком вижили.
Мені хорошо, я люблю музику!
Нічого, хорошо, я вже звикла.
І в тому році дуже багато допомагали.
І в мене ж будинок так згорів, оце як оці ж будинки.
Сильно багато згорілого, цегли, блоків.
Допомагали, приїжджали автобусами, приїжджали і допомагали.
Оце ж клуб, клуб прибирали…
Здрастуйте, і ти участвуєш, Ромка?
А, собі… Зрозуміла. Це наш завклуб.
Доля цегли зі спортзалу теж хвилює місцевих.
Волонтери планують з неї будувати нові будинки в іншому селі - Лукашівці.
Кажуть, що відновлювати Ягідне почали вже чимало іноземних організацій,
а в Лукашівці такого немає. Утім не всі жителі Ягідного з цим згодні.
Неприємно, що вивозять.
Хай би у нас - сараїв немає.
І в мене ж будинок-то пообіцяла Латвія збудувати.
А сарай же ніхто не обіцяє.
Мені ж ніде ні курочки, ніде нічого діти.
А в нас цеглу вивозять.
Ну так дали б мені, щоб добудувати ту решту.
Чого ж мені не дати?
Тим часом у Лукашівці теж триває робота.
Це один з п'яти будинків, які за рік збудували в селі волонтери.
Уже є стіни, вікна, дах.
Але внутрішніх робіт ще чимало.
Оця булька має бути по центру плюс-мінус.
І ти тоді виставляєш сам цей рівень по рівному.
Сергій – єдиний професійний будівельник у цій команді,
але працює як волонтер.
Він керує процесом і навчає інших.
Наприклад, на наступних вихідних мене не буде, я їм дам фронт робіт,
покажу, що до чого, як робити, і вони самі без мене нормально впораються.
Тому в них, можна сказати, вже є деякий досвід навіть,
тому що всю цю проводку, наприклад,  вони тягнули самі,
я тільки розмальовував, куди, що, де має йти, все.
Вони все самі роблять. Розумні. Якщо розумні, працьовиті, то в них все вийде, я думаю.
Пані Тамара - власниця цього будинку.
Поки що вона живе у сусідів.
Про колишню домівку залишилися лише спогади:
війна зруйнувала її вщент.
Загорілося все.  Мабуть, касетна ота, що горить, запалило воно її.
А з хати загорівся гараж, загорівся хлів.
А в мене були і свині, і кури, все повбивало.
І діти, в мене внучок, 8 днів, приїхали сюди, рятуватися в село.
Так у погребі, у погребі все сидів.
8 днів дитя - сиділо у погребі місяць.
Так переживали, як воно буде.
Після звільнення села за нього взялися волонтери.
Тепер для пані Тамари вони - майже як рідні.
Хоча спершу жінка не вірила, що, як вона каже,
"діти" і завали розчистять, і будинок з нуля зведуть.
Спочатку ж вони розгребли все це.
Два дні по 50 людей розгрібало.
Ну, а потім - я і не сподівалась - приїжджає прораб Слава з Андрієм, і міряють хату.
Ну що, ви хочете, щоб у вас будинок був?
Кажу, ну звісно, хочемо, а що, ви можете зробити?
Вони сміються - ну, спробуємо.
Ну, я думаю: ну, діти, ну, що вони, вони ж...
Ну, зовсім не за спеціальністю.
Ну, це і прораб же у нас такий Слава.
Він їх учив, а вони хотіли знати, як це - будівництво.
От їм цікаво було.
Він розказав, прийде - не так, переробляйте.
І так дівчата клали, стіни клали дівчата!
Ну, подивлюся - як ті мурашечки.
Після робочого дня - ночівля в наметах.
Озеро, багаття, зграї комарів.
На рейв чи дискотеку - нема сил.
Але за тиждень більшість із цих хлопців і дівчат повернуться знову.
Вони вірять, що відбудувати Україну можна саме так.